Shaktar the first guy I thought of when
I heard this news the other day
of course I talked to you and Charles
and Kenny
later that afternoon but then I saw that
you had gotten a text from Coby that
morning Shareef had gotten one what how
do you how have you been over the last
48 hours well as you know it's already
been the last couple months been really
tough lost my little sister and been
sleeping I've been doing the normal
things that I usually do I work we laugh
we kid we joke when I get back home then
we'll get me out of the say she's gone
it was just hurts so the other day I'm
downstairs working out with my son -
Shakir my nephew Columbus and my love
enough he comes in crying and he showed
me his phone
and I snapped at him suddenly get out of
my face get it away from you know we
live in a world where anything could be
photoshopped
anything could be hoaxed I didn't want
to believe it and then I got the call
from you Charles Kenny everybody called
me and then we found out it was
confirmed and having felt the pain that
sharp in a while
47 years old - lost - grandmother's lost
- Sarge lost my sister and now I lost a
little brother
we names will be attached together
for what we did
people always ask about our relationship
and I tell them it's just like me and
Charles got to strong minded people that
are going to get it done that way we're
gonna say certain things the respect
that never be lost when it comes to be
inside the lines and when I've said me
and I said we did that's with me and
Charles that's what we do it was sort of
like a triple triple stabbing to the
heart because after you cry and wondered
about that then I get back on the in and
that Rick Fox's on the plane so now I'm
obviously keeping more I'm calling Rick
he's not answering so now I'm like
what's going on and then the final blow
his lovely daughter was with them on the
helicopter you know we every time I saw
his lovely wife in this kids same thing
I do it with Kenny's kids and DeWitt's
kids hi my name is uncle chef I don't
know if they know mr. Bassel it doesn't
matter I just I am uncle Shaq I try to
make them laugh and
he would do the same thing Sharif called
me devastated I said Kobe just texted me
to check and see how he's doing and he
used to do that from time to time you
know just makes me think that and in
life sometimes instead of holding them
back certain day we should just do
d wait oh we are we up here we work a
lot and I think a lot of times we take
stuff for granted
like I don't talk to you guys as much
like what does that need you to the fact
that we're not gonna be able to Joe get
his Hall of Fame ceremony when I'm going
to be able to say hi I got five you got
four the fact that we're not gonna be
able to say if we would stay together we
could have got 10 those are the big you
can't get back with the loss of my
father but my sister I'm up there that's
the hall that wish I could just say
something to him again
I thought my talking was when we were
here and I seem to get 50 and he got 60
a lot of time I spoke to him and I just
wish I could you know so it definitely
changes me I have to it's not working
like you guys know what I do I work
probably more than the average guy but I
just really have to now just take time
to just call and say I like Rick Fox
call finally called me said that I liked
it he shall call me so I'm gonna try to
do a better job just reaching out just
talking to the people rather than always
procrastinate because you never know
life is too short never I could never
imagine nothing like this
I was thinking the other day I've never
seen anything like this all the
basketball idols that I grew up I seal
they're old like I used to be at home
when you came to inferiority I used to
watch the great round mound of rebound
now I'm working with him I used to want
to be dr. J he used to live next door to
my mother and all I know my father used
to tell me about the three great big man
I met him I seen them in the fact that I
we lost probably the world's greatest
Laker world's great battle it's just I
listen people want to say take your time
and get better but it's gonna be on from
me I already don't sleep anyway so but I
I figured out my condolence goes out to
his family his mom his dad his sisters
the other families everybody involved
Laker organization I talked to Jeannie
and Linda and people here hurt
especially in this organization you know
some people have to get treatment and
people just just don't understand cuz
hit all of us out of nowhere
I didn't want to believe it I said
myself I hope somebody some buttface
made this up and it's not true I didn't
want to believe it and then I forgiving
all to come but the cause and then you
finally felt was concerned and just it
just you know my spirit just left my
body I just wish I could be able to say
one thing to the one last thing to the
people that we we lost because you know
once you're gone you're gone forever
and you know we should never take stuff
like that for granted